tens of thousands of women say they
suffered painful and serious
side-effects from a medical device meant
as a permanent birth control option the
device known as assure is a subject of
nearly 27,000 complaints to the FDA
since its approval back in 2002 women
have reported excessive pain severe
allergic reactions and in some cases
perforated organs and a Warner looks at
the growing concern Anna good morning
this is scary stuff good morning Gail
well asure is FDA approved but the
agency recently restricted sales of the
device to physicians who provide their
patients with a checklist outlining the
risks the FDA also gave the device a
mandatory black box warning in 2016 they
are the devices manufacturer admits
there's no way to know who might develop
problems and women who have had problems
told us the experience affected every
aspect of their lives the whole process
was very a very very dark time for me
even now Amanda Russ Michelle feels the
pain from the choice she made 10 years
ago what are you barking at it started
after Russ Michelle and her husband
decided to children were enough her
doctor recommended a newer method of
permanent birth control something called
Essure you can go back to work the next
day it's non-invasive it'll be no
problem at all he sure is a medical
device designed to prevent pregnancy
permanently without surgery a doctor
inserts two small flexible coils in a
woman's fallopian tubes where they're
supposed to build up scar tissue and
block the tubes manufacturer bear says
asure has been used in nearly a million
women worldwide and advertises it as
surgery free hormone free and worry-free
it was the worst thing I've ever pain
I've ever been through
Ross Michelle says the pain continued
along with heavy periods so debilitating
she started to miss work her doctor told
her it was likely just her age then when
the symptoms persisted said she'd need a
hysterectomy she was 38 it didn't have
support of anybody that was dealing with
the same things as me and so it was very
hard and it was very I felt like my body
was failing me it wasn't until she found
this Facebook group
she realized she wasn't alone thousands
of other women posted about problems
they experienced including pain severe
bloating and rashes
some posted images they say showed the
devices perforated a fallopian tube or
their uterus bayer declined to do an
on-camera interview but an executive
told us in a phone interview we take all
of this very seriously
he said the company's studies show the
product has low and acceptable rates of
adverse events and he said we do not see
anything that would indicate that the
risks of assure outweigh the benefits
Illinois dr. Brett Cassidy says at first
he agreed implanting Essure in 114
patients but his opinion changed he says
after a patient came back she was having
brain fog migraines joint pain in her
knees arms wrists those seem like
strange symptoms to even be linked with
a device like this in my exact thoughts
he eventually determined she needed a
hysterectomy which removed the Essure
devices along with the uterus
and what happened to her symptoms gone
completely completely gone within a week
she was feeling a hundred percent better
that was three years ago
since then dr. Cassidy says he's done
over 100 hysterectomies for women with
similar problems he's since concluded he
sure can cause reactions in some women
so the coils are made of nickel and
polyester fibers and when they're placed
in the tube it creates an inflammation
reaction but this inflammation reaction
continues in the body so you're
basically saying that these two tiny
little coils can make your whole body go
haywire yeah it's hard to it's a hard to
imagine or believe bear says
hysterectomy is not the only option for
assure removal their executive says the
reason for the complaints is hard to say
he told us a lot of those symptoms can
be hormonal II related and common as
women go through reproductive life but
the explanations aren't good enough for
a man to rust micelle but we still want
this product off the market everything
we've done is because we've we have
banged on people's doors and we don't go
away
one way those women have had
impact is on assure sales the company
confirmed to us that sales have dropped
they said they're facing challenges now
we also spoke with a doctor who is a
paid consultant for Bayer dr. Peter
Rothschild of Northern Virginia and he
told us he's implanted assured devices
in more than 1,100 patients with no
reported problems no patients coming
back to him anyway
FDA has ordered Bayer to conduct a post
market trial to compare each or
side-effects with those of tubal
ligation and that final report date is
2023 north oh and it's so disturbing to
hear the pain that these women have gone
through yes some of them say that has
really been life-altering
and bears says these are acceptable
rates you've got right numbers here
27,000 women may be affected 35,000 may
be affected you said 16,000 lawsuits
doesn't seem like acceptable rates when
you get into the multiple thousands well
and that's what women who are saying
they don't believe this is acceptable
that's why they are conducting a
campaign trying to get it taken off the
market Baer disagrees obviously thank
you Anna